Traduttore: Isabella Vercesi
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Vi è mai capitato di guardare
una foto e non riconoscervi?
Io sono una fotografa
e questo è il mio strumento.
Non sempre utilizzo io la macchina
per fare le fotografie.
Circa 350 persone sono passate
davanti a questo obiettivo,
dai bambini, agli adulti,
da persone con disagi vari,
a persone che volevano lavorare su di se
e si sono fatti un autoritratto,
compresa io.
Tutto è nato
quando mi sono trovata
in un momento di profonda crisi personale;
è stato allora che ho conosciuto
una persona importante,
la fotografa spagnola Cristina Nuñez.
Lei ha rivoluzionato
il mio modo di utilizzare la fotografia
e anche la mia visione,
attraverso il metodo
che lei stessa ha inventato,
la "Self portrait experience",
l'esperienza dell'autoritratto,
che è un modo per esplorare
la propria creatività e individualità
e trasformare le proprie emozioni in arte.
Io sono qua come testimone
per raccontarvi questo metodo.
Circa il 95% degli adolescenti
con cui ho lavorato
ha definito questa
esperienza "liberatoria".
Qualcuno mi ha detto:
"Questa è la foto della vita".
Qualcun'altro mi ha detto:
"Mi hai aperto nuovi orizzonti,
ora so che posso vedere
anche altro nelle persone".
E qualcuno mi ha detto:
"Tu non sai nulla di me,
eppure mi hai fatto una radiografia".
Una volta, una persona mi ha chiesto:
"Ma tu sei una psicologa?"
No, io sono una fotografa
e vorrei portarvi con me
a fare un viaggio
per capire in cosa consiste il metodo
e farlo attraverso il mio lavoro.
Vi è mai capitato
di essere da soli in un set?
In questo caso vi lascerei
da soli in un set fotografico.
Io faccio l'allestimento,
allestisco tutto il set
secondo la mia visione estetica
e poi faccio l'inquadratura
in base anche al rapporto
che si viene a creare tra me e voi.
Poi ci siete voi,
con il vostro materiale grezzo,
le vostre emozioni.
A questo punto,
vi chiedo di fare alcune foto,
vi chiedo di cercare un'emozione,
di sentirla e di rappresentarla.
Vi chiedo di urlare silenziosamente
e poi vi chiedo di ascoltarvi,
perché in questo metodo
ascoltarsi è fondamentale.
A questo punto, vi lascio da soli
ed esco fuori dal set.
In pochi minuti,
simulerete il processo creativo
che farà parlare l'inconscio
con il linguaggio dell'arte.
Rientro nel set, guardiamo le foto,
però vi chiederò di guardare le foto
come se steste guardando un'altra persona.
A questo punto, nell'immagine
sarete autore, colui che ha scattato,
soggetto, colui che è nella foto,
e spettatore, perché vi state guardando.
Ora andiamo alla ricerca dell'opera:
l'opera è un'immagine
che ha molteplici significati,
spesso contrastanti tra loro,
ma questi significati
parlano del genere umano,
parlano di qualcosa
che riguarda tutti noi.
Che cosa vedere in questa immagine?
La vulnerabilità,
ma anche la forza e la determinazione
nel raggiungere i propri obiettivi.
I bambini imparano
a nominare e a riconoscere
le emozioni che gli appartengono.
Il girone dell'Inferno dei violenti,
un guerriero che urla per la vittoria
e poi i tatuaggi sul suo corpo
sono ancora tutta un'altra storia.
La sacralità.
L'adolescenza è un momento
particolarmente esplosivo,
di grande ricerca
e questo metodo
aiuta i ragazzi a esprimersi
e a poter comunicare
al mondo chi sono davvero.
Dolore, rabbia, disperazione,
ma se io imparo a vedere,
a nominare, a riconoscere
ciò che mi appartiene,
allora a questo punto
forse riesco a voltare pagina
e vedo forza, vedo coraggio.
La madre.
La Madonna ai piedi del Cristo in croce.
Ogni volta che vedo
questa immagine, io mi emoziono.
Trovo che sia estremamente molteplice
per le emozioni
che comunica il suo sguardo.
C'è rabbia, tristezza, paura,
determinazione, dignità
e poi nel suo sguardo
si vedono tutti i tempi,
nel passato lontano
e nel futuro lontano
ed è anche qui ed ora,
in profonda ricerca su di sé.
È Toro Seduto.
Sta guardando le persone
e sta dicendo:
"Questo e tutto ciò
che brilla è apparenza,
io so chi siete veramente,
non mi ingannate".
Tutte queste sono storie epiche,
che aiutano le persone
a dare significato alla propria storia
e aiutano a vedere
la grandiosità dell'essere umano.
Cosa guardiamo noi oggi,
quando guardiamo le foto
che abbiamo scattato?
Guardiamo ciò che possiamo vedere,
ciò che possiamo riconoscere,
ciò che possiamo acquisire.
Possiamo vedere
qualcosa di meraviglioso
che va contro le etichette che
di solito ci diamo, o ci danno gli altri,
e la nostra dignità
e autostima aumentano.
Ci si può guardare nelle foto,
ci si può riconoscere.
E questo metodo è un'esperienza
estremamente importante,
perché aiuta la crescita
personale e anche la cura di sé.
Grazie.
(Applausi)